[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello welcome evening who game of Zen's
theatre welcome back to our last night
of our gamer zones watch party season 6
tonight
I'm Adam malamat and tonight I'm Craig
mallet and what if they thank you to
everyone who's been here for all four
nights and you know all the families out
there this has been it's been maybe the
greatest party ever
this is even more been more successful
entire festival this is better and it's
better because because this party has
game of zone so the premiere is gonna be
of the new episode tomorrow at what time
baby
noon all right Craig what's turn
standard time
Craig what's an acting video oh it's a
great question Adam so since season 5 I
have done a thing that we call acting
videos in which i reenact every single
shot of every episode basically most
shots in order to help direct the
character animation because our styles
so photorealistic that when we don't get
all the little subtle facial movements
right sometimes the characters can look
a little weird or stiff so it helps to
see a real human acting out the parts
with all the little nuances and comedic
timing that we try to capture in games
don't you have a question Adam I just
want to say this basically an acting
video a Craig what my intelligent
younger brother is trying to tell you is
that Craig basically acts out all the
parts and he does it and we give it to
the animators as a video of him acting
is every literally every character and
it takes him forever but it allows our
animators
to basically get these day acting good
so let's roll
Craig's acting video this is for this
one part of the Dirk episode this is
just a sample I can't wait to share the
core with you and the legendary sir Dirk
would you like to see him you see it's
like he's a spirit is strong but I am
afraid there is not much time left
okay he's down to ten minutes a battle
my hair is cut you will make him very
happy sir Dirk
remember you can fight for this house
for as long as you like don't draw but I
don't have much time left
maybe only six seasons of its that's
fine that's totally fine is now a good
time this is like an artist yes yes Dirk
saw someone special wants to see you
hello my euro father you shaved your
beard Tyson
oh that's a Kristaps Chris all stops
you're on Elsa now freaks I am yeah Lord
mark this is truly a wonderful gift
nothing almost makes up for the time I
took a giant pay cut okay to stay with
house Mouse Charley Paulson like some
really weird episode of Silicon Valley
or a beta or orcs yeah yes so so that's
that is there's one of those for every
single episode of gamma zones since
season five but they're locked away in
the game of zones fault fault deep
underground so now I think we're gonna
get started with season six of game of
zones Adam is one thing you want to say
real quick how are they one thing which
is a couple things before we get into
things want to explain a couple things
one is that we're gonna try not to talk
too much over the videos but we gotta
say some fun facts about them if you
want to watch the videos and
the whole thing you can find them on
YouTube this is gonna be the fun fact
version of that and then between the
videos we're gonna answer questions from
you guys and before we get started we've
got a lot to show and just answer one
important question that everybody wants
to know which is why is gamma zones
ending and the recent gamers owns is
ending is not that bleacher report
cancelled it it is that we are what
we've been doing medieval basketball
jokes for a long time and we want to try
something different
try something new and we also feel that
there's some sort of like something's go
on too long and we don't wanna be a
thing that goes on too long and so now
that game of thrones ended it feels like
an elegant time to try and wrap it up in
a nice way you'll be the judge of
whether or not we did that so hey and if
we didn't do it then hopefully it's
still an interesting homage to Game of
Thrones anything you want to add Craig
Malin but I think you said it all let's
so let's get into it all right so we
actually begin before season 6 with the
Christmas special we had dropped a
surprise Christmas episode this year
lastly this was the birth of the coab
editions yes there was a sect of Kobe
fans in LA that are such diehard Kobe
fans that even with the arrival of
LeBron and we assumed that they would
never want to root for LeBron they would
never accept him as the king of LA
overdue and it was very similar to the
sons of the harpy in Game of Thrones we
felt like this underground society that
was trying to preserve the former rule
in the city if you look at the crowd you
see a bunch of like Lakers memes like
Lakers bro the guy who took office
somewhere warm and the guy who has the
Lakers fell over that guy what's the
guy's design guy whatever I would think
oh yeah I can't because like also is in
it you also see a lot of the fans from
the Sixers episode that are the combined
faces that are early day and Danny
DeVito
I want you and there's also some ID
towards Lopez no Wayne Jack Nicholson
yeah
we're honest tiny answer later that
night no it's a fun fact about gamers
owns all the stars in the sky are
accurate droughts and that's because
Craig my brother got his master's in
astrophysics and now he does I try to
use that degree to make stars accurate
that's about it I would I went to
Emerson College and where I learned how
to use a digital camera that is obsolete
Stephenson right now blowing on LeBrons
potatoes before he was trying to clone
the bronze we see how things have
changed change he's still blowing things
still glowing on LeBron but now it's
word is help LeBron instead of
hinderance can't run it by QC when it's
live baby they don't accept LeBron he's
a soft [ __ ] you can't play defense all
right let me try tell me if I could win
back the families of Cleveland I can
certainly win the hearts of a few crazy
I want to kind of be quiet over there Co
Venetians Paris Los Angeles give them a
chance like you I have much respect for
Kobe cuz he's never be Kobe brother I'm
not trying to be yeah he's better than
you okay well is there anything I could
possibly do to win you over
gave us a billion go what else Kobe
tattooed on his head no hunter
championship
I go with that yes okay you got winner
six championships Simon what you realize
cool be only one five yeah but he's a
closer [ __ ]
finishes nice I finish according to the
analytics maesters I'm actually more
clutch than Kobe nah Kobe's a killer
like a Mamba well I built a shoe Wow
oh you built a school yeah that's what
you're soft yeah you have nothing to
prove to these so a lot of them were
like improv you just improv them and
what I like about it is how natural the
conversation tell ya I just recorded or
kind of voices randomly set a bunt to
think that that Kobe fan could say
basically it was LeBron talking tight
[Music]
then stitched together all the funniest
full tapes and like filled in the
details
[Applause]
and you know one of the reasons it was
so sad to lose kobe amongst many reasons
is because he was such a big part of our
story and he we made a lot of content
about him and we are so you can at the
end you have the Kobe's torch that he
refused to pass was light lit on the
wall there is a little detail some
people may or may not notice that all
right you want to take a question and
then oh yes questions okay
so how did you guys how did you guys
think of siege this is from LG so4 to
one of our oh geez guy who's been here
for nine after night and he is one of
our great great for day or the family
Hall of Fame how did you guys think of
cjm for Space Jam and it really is just
that like space is it like space wasn't
really a well you can speak to this
Craig yeah yeah basically a space I mean
space was a concept but it was like the
sea was that Hema frontier at the time
yeah whereas like space there was no
chance you're gonna go to space but at
this point people are still exploring
the oceans so instead of Space Jam it
was the C's greats so it's like CJ we're
thinking of doing celestial Jam but fish
are easy to work with and stars yeah it
worked out great for the end
Kairi psoriasis why did you add the LA
fraud in the banner now the reason we
did that it's because there was an
actual LeBron banner that was two-faced
by Kobe fans in LA and that's a
reference to that and then as we pivot
into this next episode notice how I use
the word pivot which is a basketball
term so that's a cool thing that's
relatable out and yeah but uh Ernie
Chang says who got to act out Jimmy
Butler going nuts so that was that was
me I was Jimmy that was your crazy one
yeah oh it's one of my craziest voices
scariest voices that we go Jimmy
F in but liya
all right so anyway let's uh lead let
that voice carry us into the direwolf
which is the story of what happened he
exact retelling of what happened and
then Soto Jimmy Butler yeah there's no
footage is a basically a documented the
last dance for that what happened yeah
we had to wait to provide the only
footage of it
that was a reference to the trade that
was rejected where Dom orientation
Rockets offer for today for four from
Trump X for Jimmy Butler who handled my
leash that's a case and good at hard be
returning to practice today yeah so he
no longer wants to be traded so when
Taylor one of like my favorite
characters underrated it doesn't really
cousins the muffin makes it boy so
answers that is great oxidation we
looked up the local cuisine that was s
by CC 204 oh that's just doing gotta
love the intensity brings even to
practice so that's the muffin boy
fun fact on the model way we had to give
him a head for animation purposes and we
gave him Jason Kidd's head but you never
see it because it's like above the frame
it's a really frightening image now this
beam was meant to be like more of an
audio you kind of hear the things
happening and you don't see as much but
like the way it worked out the way we
ended up being boarded like this we end
up showing like a lot more of the
violence than we intended to how our
storyboard ours Halle this incredible
storyboard and just so funny to us that
we decided to show all the stuff you had
the goat dunking and everything we were
just wrapping up when we saw it and
we're like we've got to do this but then
it became like an animation challenge
because to do this kind of action with
this level of detail characters with not
and this woods
well second city seeing some really
great questions coming in guys like this
when I say comes from an is your
wonderful this Timmy is a big reference
this is based on an actual Street in
Philadelphia well not really it's sort
of it's like it's like art design on one
side in cotton
yeah it's a combination yeah you know
how that worked out and if they would
have won the finals if quite and make
that job that's how that worked out so
let's pause it right there let's answer
a couple questions there's uh there's a
couple uh couple good ones here so one
question is who would win in a game to
21 Craig or Adam and I listen we've had
no the ambition this is Randy Gann as
this and it would be Craig Craig is a
little bit better at basketball than I
am and was really sad when that thank
you
really I but now he always barely beats
me but we haven't played in like fire
it's true it might be worth but I give a
tap and I'm physically stronger than me
but I'm just a little bit more athletic
and I have really long arms
yeah I'm just more compact and Craig is
like lankier so like I I my ground game
you me better a shot put Mike Craig
could strike from a distance but if I
tackle him get to the ground it's over
no I do not do MMA but I just think that
would be the case luckily it hasn't come
to that okay so the the tristan james
says will the last season of gamers owns
be as bad as the last season of Game of
Thrones and all I'll say to you is this
oh yeah
you have to you have to watch to find
out but let's just say we're always
trying to parody Game of Thrones so if
you think that the last episode of Game
zones is bad and you think that the last
episode the last season of Game of
Thrones is bad then we are just
parroting that if you think it's good
then then we're not any other any
questions jump out you Craigs
there's some good ones are there well no
I think let's keep moving we got a lot
to get through so yeah let's keep moving
let's go to episode tears roll the
journey man I love this episode no this
is one of my favorite all-time scenes
yeah sometimes I love Grizz the donkey
driving the carriage blessed by the gods
to choose my own and keep teasing see
damn I no one realizes at this point
they're gonna get a CC Jam at the end
but I am said the time you know we just
kept in two minutes else or two not to
be confused with Stevie jams which is
when you like you add a bunch of people
to email reassembling what remained of
my shattered spirit I love that plan on
the tree benches mmm peace we actually
spent yesterday because if you were
travelling in the direction it's Dona
Phoenix he's coming he probably going
pro yeah yeah and if you're travelling
there what would be the cardinal
direction there or what would be the
directions of each of these cities on
this signpost oh my god no one cares
about the song from the beginning of
that like I think it's so beautiful the
song so we found the world to freeze
back or when marshawn's riding in a
carriage oh how the fickle tides of
I love the poetry of this mean some of
our finest writing
you notice our horse walks are getting
even better each season we're getting
better at it
I love the musical transition here to do
use Jennifer I've received your Raven
and I beseech you understand I am sir I
try every day to bring you the race rate
rating there is there is a contract with
you I'm trying Jennifer Jennifer I'm
trying great names you might remember
from 25 years ago when the NBA was
called a lose so this is now and this is
actually a very direct scene reference
from Game of Thrones when the Hound is
captured by the Brotherhood but to none
than yours lets him get in your head and
reason we decked out do and wag is
because we we wanted we knew we just got
traded so we've got to be funny to like
get them all into it I don't know first
of all I supposed to have a huge in the
show and I really like a target friends
that's the price you pay in the game is
Suns world if you're good enough at
basketball to make the NBA good enough
be the best and you are right nice to be
following good vibes I'm also like we
have same agent and he says it might
affect my minutes those are motto it's
Walter I'm signing with one of my
favorite jokes no
yes he's full of it everybody knows
House Warriors over the gold cap they
can't afford you know it's probably
mid-level exception exception I of
course know what that isn't fully
understand my mind is buzzing for iron a
heartache here's one of the top GOP
tracks we realize later the accidentally
ripped off dragons okay we're both big
sky retire sometimes like melodies you
don't know where they come from and you
realize that came fro not expect it to
be a bastard but a coward - I'd rather
die the chair the court with curry no no
I'm sorry I mean the good I mean Steph I
was slightly concerned this wind and
I'll just say this that curry was very
probably 100 to zero if it played what I
want it's very well yes defeat can only
come from with he's really good brothers
you know his brother is deaf curry this
is the so we updated it after the next
fastest trade habit because we wrote
this before Nik Stauskas got kicked off
of Blazers
[Music]
[Music]
some harmonies in this version and then
next like 12 teams and 14 minutes buzz
it everywhere on okay I want to take
some questions yeah you want a far crack
also I read a commenter said someone
hates when we say we're gonna take some
questions now sorry to that person so
let's take some questions now someone
asked why do you spell sir
ser that's a great question Johnny quid
one the reason is because george RR
martin spells sir ser in the books and
so we wanted to stick to that someone
else asks can create a plane I of Steve
Pellegrino okay so our friends okay okay
yeah I wasn't sure if that was like a
different our tech channel to help this
deep belly be my mascaras out of our
talented amazing co-workers in the in
the on the production side of things and
so Craig could you explain the the chimp
picture yes is to explain picture behind
me yeah I have a chimp I actually that's
not give you google search chimp on the
images that picture shows up I just
printed it out and put it in a frame as
just a reminder that we're all just apes
at the end of the day and we should stay
humble you know because we're just got a
real component shoulder drinks oh all
right I want to read I wanted a question
from Stephen my who had some good
questions yesterday I was on back and
looking but uh
we missed some of them but he says maybe
it's the red shirt but Adam is giving
off a merry a vibe and I say Mario not
Mario and that turns people crazy and
Craig's got a Luger's e-field
it's a medium body oil it's me I'm the
second best there you go
okay good all right let's roll into the
next episode is probably this is the one
that won the competition for best
episode Gramma's owns episode of all
time and I think I probably agree though
I do love Van Gundy Island this to me is
a top three episode it's this you know
and it's probably the best all-around
episode in a story we're actually a
little worried it was gonna be too
legitimately sad so let's say we yeah
yeah let's roll it and we'll talk over
the episodes - no can hear any of the
dialogue so this is a follow-up to
Dammam rather monaco it's like a triple
switch or something exactly do we
studying house warriors defensive
tactics against King James right here
goodbye their tactics it was determined
we have the talent we just need smart
strategy and for the gods the really the
same book from father of balls I don't
know if anyone's noticed that but it's
that last page in the last episode of
season 4 when Magic Johnson is Green
called the Laker kids it's the same book
they're studying the history of LeBron
James's battles also out on facts by the
way there's a fossil the gods the me
guess I was gonna say that my puppy just
snuck up behind me and they made a huge
would think it's terribly smelling far
you'd give anything and you can't see it
but I feel so cute but you farted and it
smells they have their room decorated
this is what I wanted to say I don't
know I can follow that the room is
decorated with a fossil of a raptor
dribbling a fossil of a things are
called ammonites
um I took a basketball in like the
Precambrian era Oh No so this scene is
based on one of the saddest scenes from
Game of Thrones and another spoiler
alert major spoiler alert it's a scene
where Stannis first you don't want to
hear this oh no I turn away
there will be no see oh yeah we wanted
to find the saddest scenes to portray
one of the saddest raids this is where
we learn that Jon Snow is part of a
clone army if Jon knows I was supposed
to be my spoiler whatever those didn't
make sense the way I phrased it so
follow does fun fact about this episode
it actually we got nominated for a
Sports Emmy we submitted this episode
and they liked it
Adam screams wait fun fact Craig that's
more like a fun fun brag oh yeah no big
deal we got that night coordinate yeah
we win you know how could you not win
with a inflatable Raptor that so there's
the the famous nurse meaning that we
included last-minute with team of the
appropriate reaction to seeing a giant
inflatable monster emerge one thing that
is bumps me a little bit here is that I
feel like with all the pine trees the
[ __ ] I'll be you yes true buddy's got
very thick fabric it's made out of an
animal hide I guess I'm putting its
mouth down a giant spike yeah
I have a question Adam does the trade
Raptor have a brain inside of it's like
inflatable head no the trade Raptor is
actually its brain is a network of
neurons that has runs around this leg so
it's a picks in this world are
represented by ping-pong balls not
really kind of just became a thing and
doesn't make you much sensitive because
that's not Excel works
Damon Conway 1/3 Ibaka were you when the
Raptors away how happy were you in the
Raptors won because how this episode
looks in retrospect really happy
no well ok I was unhappy that to be the
Sixers because we're fixers fan oh but
they want they'd be this mixers the
thing is this I also always want the
team that beats my team and the playoffs
to win so that way I could say that my
team won for the best and they're the
second best team for me his boots are a
reference to the actual New Balances
that Kauai they they put out for Kauai
by I don't know if it's actual shoes
said that I think I changed it but I
wish they did I'm not exactly I think
that like Times New Roman so many of
them or something yeah but I but I know
that those the actual ones I'm not sure
I'm not like I'm a poser sneakerhead
anyway so we have a few more questions
we're gonna get to we got some thirsty
fan links here hoping we can read their
questions and I would like to to fulfill
their need so let's see here we got uh
our David's ISA so the new episode is
gonna be longer proportionally and I'll
say this there's only four episodes but
they are a little longer and there one
may or may not be the longest episode
you've ever seen of gamer zones also
here characters than you've ever seen
I'll say that so here's the question I
was concerned player game says why is
serge ibaka depicted with just a helmet
on and it's kind of like we so we had
him in a helmet in the serge ibaka trade
scene and then we had a special helmet
from and then we're going through
players we just kind of like hoons head
needs to get designed and we're like
well Serge Ibaka has his helmet he can
wear that and we were hoping to get to
his head being designed but we never got
to it and then Serge Ibaka visited the
office and he came around looking at the
animation and he while we were animating
the wraptor scene and we couldn't show
him his head but like all these players
were Raptors had heads players way worse
than him and we were like um so you're
actually in a helmet here's what you
look like
poor guy he's quite a very good-looking
man so I feel bad we didn't design him
yeah yeah I agree
I would definitely trade my face for his
face also like it would look weird and
yeah it would which is our Rockets
episode oh this episode fun fact oh this
episode it took us 14 drafts to get this
script done this was so long right oh my
god I need you yeah this was one of the
looks we like a pair these episodes
writing them to Jenga pieces and it's
like sometimes the Jenga pieces comes
right out and other times you're like oh
no carefully take it out and sometimes
the whole thing collapses though this
was enough Jeff yeah I think it came
together but I remember being numb to
this I was like this episode it was
supposed to be like this episode was
originally inspired by the scene in
Robin amenitized 6 when the sheriff of
rottingham sits on a catapult to show
how it works and then someone with a
believer and shoots him in the sky his
friends so they could we now supposed to
be the whole scene was that Daryl Morey
was explaining to nello how a catapult
works at the end he launches him you
know what off the team and then it
evolved into this like rah city well I
loved some of them over here like the
computers and you see the Travis Scott
head there and
oh my god here's one of the nerdiest
Easter eggs I don't ever know about the
ingredients for making a medieval rocket
or on Darryl Morris tables like the
Rock'em we valued on the salt or I
forgot what it looks like tried away
from its gunpowder the early gunpowder
materials and there's the Ambika trophy
most valuable night I write this and
that the top of the shoulders in the
Superman logo and well that's done you
can see you can see the dress of Kendall
Jenner's all moons for when from Italy
so this is where the radon they won't be
the center of the universe afternoon
yeah this scene is me know just trying
to integrate outer space into the
tortilla actually Chris that's a
reference that Galileo's Dawes discovery
of the four moons of Jupiter who's a
good Easter egg here is also there's a
target size McDonald foil because James
Harden girl thinks that are done coil
model it's not possible I can't just
suit 33s again look right here James
also in a glass case in Ireland James
party Oh
their mascot ourselves was ripped off
against the Warriors in season three
I feel bad because James Harden still
has kind of messy if any effects
no but it's middle time so this is the
model we feed her data and she gives us
answers so we wanted to lie us convey
how a computer was look in this world
and way back in the day computers
actually reference to people did
calculations they just computed all that
and so that's what makes our computer is
in this world your analytics with a
little 2sc knows basketball then I
should have oh you remember analytics
that works these are your career stats
let's feed the oh the they're creatures
they're like analytics like we're like I
don't forget exactly what it was you
remind me I forget was um you know the
movie in the descent where they go into
a cave and there's like this alternative
species of human that like crawls around
yeah it was like that's what analytics
look like they were like moving right
and they were like just weird type idea
I want to do for the computer is what
eventually began to commuters oh yeah
take it away model originally the
computer has not seen a [ __ ] rock which
are blind we're blinded because they saw
Paul George get injured but we changed
it to watch basketball mid-nineties
because there's more tasteful but well I
guess that cats out of the bag
this model is nothing but I hate them
how does this bloody thing even work I
feel bad we're we're mean to mark
another amazing vessel player who would
be me it's all relative nations needed
to run the model oh do they will do any
of you even watch basketball I got a
message from Krillin says we're nerds
good form he's not wrong this is not
round holes witnessed the dark ages of
basketball in the early aughts the
endless post plays the long tubes if we
were in this world we'd be commuters
after a second Finals appearance but
that's by the way aren't any longer the
couch now throw down Maurice big note it
turns out they're perfect for doing
double blinded analytics many became
just one of them job the rest became ref
I don't like your true shooting all
right well we really should get going
though you're beginning to taint their
judgment make it how to make it if you'd
said what they would be able to detect
or not it's all quite logical really no
no this is all wrong you're cold
heartless numbers however I read the
first chapter I can see the beauty of
that game a ten-time behind PJ Tucker
really Marquis I know you think about
Rory why did you even bring me here
because you know well boy we got a
question from sterile Owen and says oh
maybe sometimes the answer is just
sometimes I could still take any night
one of the other nuts of her walk it off
Adam feels bad I okay oh what a man II
mean New York
we're originally gonna have land in uh
in China seven hells Austin Rivers yeah
but we had to add that because they
signed off some rivers and we had to
acknowledge that because last season he
slapped Austin Rivers in the face
because we because they don't like each
other so we had had the thrown a little
thing there so a couple couple questions
here who came up with the design of the
trade Raptor so the trade Raptor this is
from bode I hope I pronounced that right
so the trade Raptor design is actually a
real based on a real Raptor mascot they
have a couple mascots and this is the
one that's a big one that does this
trick where it eats people
and then like pretends to spit out their
clothes you can Google if you Google
inflatable Raptor mascot you can see
videos of this and that's so we actually
base the design on that and then our
designers I think it might have been
Ally or or maybe Chad but they they took
it and made it a real thing Greg I am
reading through well here's one David C
says how does the watch relate to game
of zones I haven't seen all of it so
it's a bit confusing so the watch
doesn't relate to game of throw it's
more of a game of it's more of a game of
Thrones pun because they have and now
your watch has ended it's based on
people who are the Watchers on the wall
I believe yeah I mean that we're calling
our diss the watch as a reference to
Game of Thrones or like the Watchers on
the wall in the actual show we had the
watch it was sort of Steve Kerr with the
Warriors and that one episode like the
fifth episode ever made we had Russ and
the first episode with KD were at the
wall and then you had the White Walkers
beyond it but you know we've randomly
done Jon Snow and things like that
reference the watch but question last
question Oh Agis popular no geez okay
well under buts facing me which means
I'm about to get hit with another one of
her cute cute little farts anyway
chechens annoys says
in the next season are you going to
mention the coronavirus quarantine or
that's factored into any of your
episodes that's a really good question
so know we had finished writing
everything before everything started
getting crazy and we were lucky enough
to stay on schedule because our
production manager our producer Chris
wall and your Evan Matthews and another
the rest of our team were able to
convert everything over to digital and
so we didn't affect our production and
as far as the writing it's it's we
didn't consider that but our plot seems
weirdly like it might be related but
it's actually just that's just the way
things worked out it was written before
this all went down yeah anything dad
correct all right now I thought so let's
move on to the next episode let's play
we got a lot to get through this is a
good one so this is you'll remember from
the acne videos this is the scene that
I'd done the acne videos for I can't
have wild horses with you and the
another tapestry based on the Bayeux
Tapestry
if you haven't seen that he is one of
the oldest names as that it was strong
but I am afraid there is not much time
left
okay he's down to see if you can notice
that Greg's little happening and they
seem very happy
mmm so duck remember you can fight for
this house for as long as you like
Marcus is down left of you yeah this
seems loosely based on the Robert
Baratheon deathbed scene to Italy fine
now a good offer either crystal dick
someone special wants to see you
hello my euro father you shaved your
beard Jason that's Chris that Chris all
stops you're on a path through sorry Sam
sir it's just almost blind at this
party's truly wonderful yeah one thing
that's worth screw with is that like is
the people like it cooked jerk is like a
hundred years old here but like the
players are the ages
like older players are like old men the
retired players are not yukon it's okay
like reset New Age sequence mark is
actually it's about a cool guy
your grace don't care about listen
there's no respect or we the production
process just walking around everywhere
backstage chairs
oh she's younger than everyone please
understanding was that to you for 56
years
I have form only house Mavericks colors
these are Dirk actually watched this
episode live on periscope with Ernie
Johnson yes no mercy
I made no yes are we watching a
professional athlete crane mouse I
highly recommend that because I'm just
like that's the whole time but he says
that he never mind
Chris Dobbs I think we can say and swear
your loyalty
I mean house this is the birth of the
triple Dirk's by death nice you're
saying Luke advantage his name of the
next let's give House Mavericks yeah I
would actually say that Dirk so now the
original Lucas look wait hold on oh wow
actually Thomas Rinzler says it's funny
how people actually call Luca Chris
Thompson Kleber as the trouble they're
from your life you know I gotta say it's
always like weirdly affirming when
something your head becomes like a real
life I don't know it's something that's
really fun about knowing like you
contributed to the culture of like yeah
it's like yeah one of the highest
compliments it's like people started
calling Jakob hurdle Jake puddle which
is what our heritage fleebus apiece the
next me sir our next battle starts in
eight hours we need to start your
stretches oh thank you
JJ I'll be right shell if you look
really closely a strapping MBA by the
way it's supposed to be cold and he's
like four foot six and he's like he's uh
seems fat but he's so good I love it
oh it's gonna answer some questions but
I forgot there's a whole other section
[Music]
this seems based on the reason Milan
will bring it would have been moved
Rafael would let you alone yeah it was
200 gold base 200 gold foot right right
winner before this came out it's gonna
be a big baller brand collapsed the
whole scandal happened so we had to like
cross off all the logos on his stuff and
change the dialogue originally because
it was his brand yeah that's one of the
challenges of making these cartoons when
they take a long time is that things
come up and then you've gotta like
scramble those long arms it's like a
Lanza I think of the space would you let
me play power forward yes this is a
reference to the one of the first scenes
of Game of Thrones it's in the first
episode the end of the first episode
Rita and Lonzo is like our 15th brand
chef I would treat every single one of
them for just a chance to play with you
between you and me they're a bunch of
fools and overhyped
Squires even the ball boy for long
though good riddance demanders Oh from a
father and once he's gone we'll bring in
a real world we were hoping that but
that didn't end up happening is season
pal okay Tuesday's so long so be the
king of the six kingdoms do mind we have
like 100 different brands in the show so
even if bran was gonna win it would
still we still have like 12 grand we've
got rings it could be Chris tops it
could be there grows I smile
there's other ones too Oh Johnson turned
out of nowhere yes
Wow push from the greatest day in the
realm someone going to help us up I love
that gargoyles and by the way next year
[Music]
which is very anachronistic but it just
felt like the right comedic trope do you
so a couple questions - twins 2007 says
how long does it take to make the
episodes
Craig you you can speak to that yeah
ever since
now take about eight weeks to make it's
like three weeks of writing a week and a
half of storyboards and then once the
storyboards are made you need to design
all the characters and draw the
backgrounds once the characters are
designed they can be moved around by the
animators and that whole process takes a
few more weeks and then finally it's all
composited which is when you put all the
layers together so you have the
characters on top of the backgrounds and
then some special effects are added
added and then we have the all the audio
that we do is mixed by a mix house and
then we send it to you guys and that's a
tweak and and then Mac says what made
you want to design Mark Cuban like that
specifically with his clothes and well
he's he's supposed to be Elena Tyrell we
made him that in the last season and so
we just kind of stuck with it so well it
made us want to do that as we mentioned
last night is that initially we were
getting back at him because he went
after a bleacher report after police
report posted Dirk shooting an airball
and it said Dirk forever and so he like
any good owner you know went defending
his players but you know he also went
after the company that we represent and
so we had that boom boom boom right back
at him and we decided to make him Elena
Tyrel and we just kind of stuck with it
now he's one of the that's like one of
the most interesting characters in the
show in my opinion yeah
so David see that's a good question
which is how did the graphics change
over time
did you put more hours into it or it
gradually get easier to do it so
initially when we started this show it
was just Craig and I doing all the
animation so I did all the designs Craig
did all the engineering and of the of
the heads and and a lot of the animation
and backgrounds a bill and all the math
and and so I initially in the first
episode we made the heads weren't as
detailed it was more of like a Stanley
Chow it was a designer type of vibe I
was going for but like then like Mario
Chomp people thought that Derrick Rose's
Mario Chalmers and I was like okay we
gotta get these likenesses right and so
we gradually developed our style to be
more and more photorealistic and then we
got animators and designers in who are
way more talented than me and and they
were and and the graphics just the
Kalima graphics felt like the designs
just got more and more hideout better
and better quality but the problem is
the more detail they are the harder they
are to animate so things didn't
necessarily get easier because as we
push the limits of what we can do so
okay I've won well as one question I
want to answer and then we can move on I
know it's a lot of questions
what would the world map look like in
geo Z I know that outside of America
there's China's but is there any more
kingdoms
well that's from David Conway by the way
we actually have a map coming in the
upcoming season spoiler alert you will
see a map but it's not the entire world
I read the original show Bible when we
first pitched the show before the first
episode and we actually had boleros was
west of Westeros and it was in the Game
of Thrones world but we've since changed
that I think when we expanded the
universe I think that what you'd see is
it would be sort of a rough version of
the current like the actual earth map
but if you little there'll be some
changes here and there but that's about
all I'm gonna say about that because it
is
getting later and we should keep rolling
through all right so this is episode 6
the lottery this was a really hard
episode too right yeah this wasn't a
hard episode to write because like we
really couldn't figure out what the
we're like waiting for a twist like a
thief we just forced this and it turned
out to be a really great episode but I
was very skeptical of it for a long time
I didn't think I had a point was
originally gonna be like the peak the
Kingsmoot likes the end which is when
they try to pick a new King for the iron
island that was recently gonna be based
on but yeah they're gonna they're just
in a big circle in a field and they're
all gonna step forward to make the cases
of the lottery guys but it was really
hard to animate that you need so many
different head angles so we decided to
go with this format by the way shout out
to our producer and then Mack is because
he encouraged us to put the Ernie
Grunfeld statue being built in the
backgrounds as a shrine to yeah the the
GM's made Brett bed front office
positions okay well you got to pick one
representative so figure out who is the
next Dirk of the next ten seconds please
all right well I mean I'm the most
experienced well I'm clearly the face of
House Mavericks and I'm from darks
hometown so yeah I mean it's hard we all
have really good cases all right you
know what Maxie Cleaver doesn't never
give the relationship between like
marketing these players was like ended
up working really nicely teacher yeah so
so for this scene we actually had like
30 names like alternate endings for all
the possible scenarios of who was gonna
get Zion yeah oh my god this episode
came out two days before two days after
the actual lottery hide and we knew we
planned it for that and so we made 14
alternate endings for every single team
when a north mania for like all this
imagery yeah and we were obviously like
printing and go to the Sixers be the
scenario than the [ __ ] amazing ending
for that and he never got to use that
but if the pelicans were almost pretty
good so we use the the curb music there
are a few endings that were just generic
but we ended up posting all of the
collection attending 292 so you should
check those out if you haven't seen them
already
bless us Oh lottery gods with the Squa
there's another wizard reference by the
way Western powers Oh Arthur Westside by
the way asks what's the go joke and
that's actually a reference you know
robert Sarver by kevin hart away put
goats exactly but some throw we put
those in someone's office thing you'll
be funny what is in someone's office i
camera exactly here but you put goats in
the GM's office as a metaphor for them
needing to draft a goat according to you
right thank you yeah it's quietly had a
decent squats or anthony davis you want
to make a plea for house pelicans yes
read this and i know we're talking a lot
over these episodes of e of you if you
want to go watch them without us being
annoying you can do you could they're
all there and please report to youtube
and you can watch them in full but we
want to make sure that this episode
lives with us giving commentary so that
it can be
something that no it's just a different
way of watching it so we forgot to tell
the temple baby story thank you
ad house Cavs would you like to make
your case it's the God's truth Iike to
see the Squires on Flo's Karen love is
still Brienne of Tarth
that's his accent because of the scene
in the third episode ever the cap in
which she's in a hot tub with a Bron
Bron it's a penis joke look how much
healthier Kevin Love looks now that he
was redesigned he no longer looks ill
yeah finally in a few oranges and I got
some nutrients I miss you too
all right guys very complicated
relationship I feel like Kevin love's
and Ron James I feel like oh yeah that's
something I would hope someone to make
take a deep dive in we really do try
young journey sometimes characters
become so tough
I mean how many no more arbitrarily
weirdos and he became a weirdo I mean
who wouldn't want to play with Dwight
Howard this is a drunk LeBron roast and
everyone okay the first time he's been
to the lottery ten years respect for
many of these houses this is the
highlight of their season yeah oh yeah
why is that
maybe instead of looking to the gods you
all should be looking at those selves
rubbish houses with uninspiring Lord
commanders foolish another stressful
thing about this
was that we didn't know who was gonna be
mean like the lottery at the hall for a
very long time remember that there's
like three teams yeah for the playoffs
see twice has nothing in the ever magic
the magic I think was like Evan Fournier
or something for the magic yeah but once
I doesn't say anything please put in
last minute house Pelican and here we go
again with the Kirby's they because just
that was the one we chose if the
pelicans happen to get it yeah so one
thing we toyed with for the last episode
before this which was the the tampering
episode is this whole lore I wrote up
and I you know like a fever dream and it
was like this idea that when two NBA
players tamper with each other a baby is
made that is a combination of the two
players and it is like a super talented
incredible and be a baby but it's the
babies force our curse to not be
interested in basketball and so the van
Gundy is in Van Gundy Island they train
and they raise them as their own and
they they all live there the tamper
babies and so someone I forget who was
going I might have been James don't
learn someone Billy that like in a
desperate need to get talent goes and
kidnaps some tamper babies and then this
was I think this is gonna be like some
big plot but like I forget exactly this
way three episode arc yeah it was a huge
arc about tamper babies and they're
gonna be a whole team of tamper babies
yeah and you know one of them obviously
was LeBron at the Davises baby but
wasn't there something with a Jan didn't
Jan van in Tobias Harris Jayma Gundy
have a oh no no no no no you usually
were thinking of the fact that the band
people in Bank good idea was this that
all the Van Gundy and monks were all
tamper babies that were created for all
the times that Jeff and Stan tampered
with each other to try and get each
other to coach with each other or
something like that so every time I
serve a Stan or Jeff with the coach and
he said hey come be my assistant that
created a new Van Gundy tamper baby so I
know it doesn't make sense
that's why it's a cutting floor I came
in one day to the office it was like
Craig I got a picture this it's an
incredible idea and I I'm the reason
Adam goes maybe you should sleep on that
couple quick questions let's see here
why did you watch my ranks again for the
represent it's not worn it's because we
has a tire barrier says yeah we hadn't
designed he's just he's the funniest
person to just be shot down by LeBron
for that joke like I feel like it
wouldn't have worked for anyone else on
the team as well and then Matt Gibson
says was the Sun Kings Alliance a real
thing and the answer is uh no we just
felt like there was a lot of alliances
happening in Game of Thrones and we
couldn't do any so he least tried to do
one there yeah we wanna try anything
else or it bad teams that needed each
other what your own show the next
episode ah this is the controversial hot
where's our boy the guy there's guy
yesterday asking tons of questions about
the well-being of lucky and be with us
tonight you want to do see me know same
Hobbit door as the other scene with
president I'd like to pretend I tried to
make my scene so cool nothing can
actually be cool it's intentional like
many the silliness of the show know we
intend for this to be very dramatic it's
just never we never see those - too much
and the one thing more pop would have
never lost control of this house dispose
of the East lucky for you there's one
last road trip before the tournament
start
I suggest you find a way to get on
nights on the same so a lot of the
chances of this scene was that we had to
untangle know the I felt bothered by the
fact that we called the Celtics the
Spurs to the East house Celtx and I we
needed to like untangle that a little
bit and deal with that so and also the
whole Kyrie situation was just like
relatable that hold the cab that team
was just so interesting that he wrote
all our chemistry is you're feeling
cramped expansion yeah but I think those
cases where like we really show of a
little Gigi I've seen that to fill up
that has a soul box when you saw him
with House Spurs your soul and
personality go into the box so it's like
a Spurs culture thing I didn't want it
to come to this but there's too much
talent here in this room for us to be
treading water like a cereal box will
help us continue our dive into the lower
here box that things the reason nobody
heard of me in San Antonio oh yeah
that's the reason hole do it alright now
I want you to lose your eyes and place
your hand on the box lucky stone is part
do you hereby commit fully sacrifice
your soul for a good of house Celtx
so did it work or why they didn't flinch
all right who's next anyone do it okay
no lucky thank you like I love Leopard
nights
that's top three Joe my whole game is
about emotion Jalen I left your
rectangular prism no way this is the
year of really going wasn't really clear
seems like it may have been more about
Kyrie singer and I am clearly not no you
know
oops casually Smashwords like that's
umbrella Stephens best X's and O's man
I've Evan it's all box has been around
gaining a baller unfortunately they're
not more there but it was made from
shoes the original of the ones basket
from dollmaker know about me okay make
me from well you'll have to watch next
season to get real even more which
premieres tomorrow that Texas A&M I made
a whole plot of two years based on the
fact that there's a player on the team
named Time Lord or at least nickname
Tyler time erupted I'm just I'm also
Matt Gibson says so when Gordon Hayward
just matched the sole box that released
that it released why soul it did release
wise soul which means that defensively
Hawaii and then won the championship we
hope you got a soul back talking about
incredible people there's an amazing
episode we never showed in which like
Kauai lost all this confidence because
he got a soul back and then this whole
team rallied around them and we know
they had an amazing victory your Brad
Stevens you can do this commander are
you all mad do you really think he could
just come up with some magical out of
timeout play that gonna fix all of our
chemistry issues well think it's fun is
pay attention to everything that changes
in the background when time freezes
[Applause]
just Stephens has like 20 years
and everyone's frozen or I'm just stuck
[Music]
look like you've aged 30 40 years so
this is where people thought we maybe
took thing to the bar with me 2 min
explanation of Lucky's demise mostly
just Jim yeah actually maybe we were
just bored by episode 7 and we had to
get weird
there was the Wilson enough all there
that he missed lucky by like year 7 bad
news first lucky that frozen in time
with me unfortunately for lucky he swore
a blood oath to always perform during
timeouts obviously never thinking he
will yeah but he kept performing he was
juggling dancing doing those wacky dunks
man don't always wacky dunks this is
based on the jaws scene bouncing bulls
oh yeah this is a deep cut so this is
based on the scene in Jaws where I can
remember his name but the boat captain
like the boat captain it tells that
really dark story or four-mile in like
World War two like all these guys who
had their ship blown up or like picked
apart slowly by sharks and we modeled
this story totally after that so what's
the good news
well I came up with a few pretty clever
inbound plays that might get us to the
second round
that second round line is updated once
we found out they're eliminated that was
a scene it could go either way
moment of silence for lucky let's let's
guys let's see those f's
let's see those F's for lucky ok yeah
all right cool
so let's and any other questions here
someone says why does lucky sound like
Mickey Mouse well there the road our
stream I'll pull down and good night
everyone we were sued but I don't know
it's just that he felt like that was
like the quintessential classic cartoon
voice and we gave him a voice that has a
similar vibe but it's definitely not
that Mouse's voice so Matthew asks Oh
beachie how long did it take to come up
with all the writings on Stephens board
it's great question actually what we did
was we went there's a couple really
hardcore Celtics fans at the police
report office shout-out to Lee Schecter
and no example and we asked them
basically like what are all the craziest
schemes that you could think of that
Brad Stevens could be writing on that
board in order to figure out their
chemistry problem yes so Adam Juvia and
they really they really helped us with
this episode like to shape and make sure
that we got all the right guys for the
right things also I want to give a quick
shout out to Dan Moore and Matt Hale who
are writers on the season incredible job
matt is a Clippers fan you formerly
Lakers fan and Dan is a Sixers fan and
if you get a chance to check out his
erotic 6 was born that was what that was
that was what what his audition know
that he was atop the Phillies stuff is
really good yeah I like it we just did
both he does he writes erotica for both
the Phillies and the Sixers and he's
incredibly talented dude check him out
depending on - all right let's let's
dive into the season finale of season 6
I love this first scene I think it's
just really well done yeah I just wish
that he went to the Clippers to get that
we've ruled the world from edge to edge
Thank You Kyrie I'll be in touch so this
is based on Iran Greyjoy trying to
seduce Cersei yeah this is like a really
asking questions bad scene you do
reference like the scene it were
referencing is just like so gory
no you'll just be greedy and so there
you see rich climbing Katie's agent with
his Nick stuff underneath a December
lens
we were like confident that he was going
through the dick I heard you said nice
it doesn't fly up to me after the bottle
you were the opponent if he liked me as
your opponents but we thought a good
place for a movie the Clippers know we
want anything at home Beverly to make it
better the Pat Beverley is also a
character who happened it's like a
player who's really interesting and we
really didn't get a chance to show and
see so we thought it'd be kind of
unexpected Robby see emiram dates it
helps yeah he was talking about alive
missing these playoffs him I also like
going with the alternate Warriors
jerseys for like the darker color as
they like a reference to Cersei and how
she became evil and more more darkness
that incident I've drawn well I mean
like everyone in Game of Thrones started
wearing all black by like the end of it
just completely gave up I like the light
color medieval stuff well then I guess
good Thomas Rinzler asked why does
Beverly's clipper uniform let's given
the others in the series so every house
has a couple different outfits but also
I think we wanted his to look a little
bit more like your honor and we kind of
like a year on version I think so yeah
you know listen to your burner you can't
win with those cuts we also notice the
banners in the background are the same
banners from the free market episode
it's a really really good regular season
ah snakes if you're trying to lure me to
house Clippers
doing an awful job you know now that I
think about it house Clippers would be a
terrible fit I mean we all know you own
a little reverse psychology the old nah
Pat Beverley reverse psychology he's all
selling new heads to Mack slots he gave
us a shout-out for this episode by the
way so Patrick Beverley bunch of high
mafia loyal dogs just looking for their
alpha
it's almost too easy
and besides you came Wyman doesn't like
to go to the next be so unfair to King
James upstaged night after night in his
own City stage night after night in his
own cities second a man who was always
you know for a free agent or very loyal
house catalyst read about these always
finish yeah okay d I'm Claire smoke came
to sit in the throne you've been very
generous with your time also uh Rocco
Clay's famous dog so this scene we
really wanted someone asked before about
to be went the Raptors were actually
wanted the Bucks the way on so that we
can show that we added that swipe to his
head and we had to man actually the
original scene was for them losing
because it was supposed to be sad wasn't
that they were picking him up afterwards
I don't know I think you know they were
sad thought they're gonna lose to the
Warriors but any pixel wise well then
they'll are friggin Raptors which means
it's going to be hard for us to even
make confidence finals voice the series
actors bought it be wrong
he's a very similar to bloody debug
there's only so many different there's
Eric Bledsoe reference to us I do want
to be where instead of I don't want to
be or anything defeated but we are not
without hope for we have the honor of
fighting low camera guys
true greatness not just of skill but of
character the king of the north may rule
the east for now but I recognize only
one true king and his name is long and
full of lettuce or palace all back there
it is all fed from Steve's original
season
stay ahead from other retirement last
year I fought side by side with King
James I to the Barristan Selmy voice in
the east
nothing my career I was wrong I can only
imagine what heads we have under those
guys the King all remember the days when
Brassica that was like wish I had to be
quiet so where's the dignity and respect
of this house we have not known hope
like this since the days sir Alcindor
the big oak and it's all mine
[Music]
[Music]
it's really good animation I love that
shot nine years I sort of point out that
every single character from the win this
shot I'm coming out to hold my hand mine
the design of their costume is based on
a pun related to their name we never
actually published that we like in the
episode or in there that we but to
reclaim my technically images everyone
its Rondo Rondo is the sea turtle okay
yeah but there's a reason this
connection to everyone so you got like
Lakota James got barnacles that shark
and some shaft bradley seal to whale
McGee
the seahorse that does seahorse things
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a lot in there I
[Music]
there's lots right here before we oh
yeah this next one is the bridge to our
current season before we get to it take
a quick question here
shout out Paul Lauri okay he's my guy
from my a Mersenne days okay and he says
do you guys do any voice modulation for
certain characters and the answer is yes
we'd have to because we do all the
voices were so many different characters
we do modulate down that helps us with
bigger guys because bigger guys like
have bigger pipes than we do so when
there's like big characters it's useful
to use that tool to help us diversify
the sounds we can make but and real
quickly preface to this episode so this
episode is actually the first part of
our five-part finale for parts we
haven't seen you and they're gonna start
airing tomorrow at noon but this is the
beginning of that story arc so pay
attention to what happens here because
things are getting juicy in boleros
hater news little juicy by the way moons
are months in our world we don't say
months we say moons because the moon
goes around the earth roughly once a
month it's a little less there's Mugsy
bows
[Music]
someone's coming hey what a free-agent
come into house Hornets we have to blow
the Charlotte wall nice giant captions
for you guys there wait case you want to
watch this from very far away there's no
rider just the horse love how creepy
dark this episode is to see if there's
little Charlotte Hornets flying around
in the Swan day defense in this realm
anymore that's the summer also very
weird joke there he's doing a selfie
shot with a raven and then when we
changed the camera angle you see he's
holding a raven up so that was like the
Ravens POV the beginning of this and
we're sorry guys that the captions
aren't covering the entire screen you're
hoping and it'd just be worse I'm just
getting a blessing for anyone who likes
to read my lord commanders have informed
me that the pies already so everybody
says with me it's time for me
people aren't that excited about me
climb under and didn't meet by Monday
she should call it amaze me pause
because he's so cool you know I love pal
corny LeBron is by the way I love how
unabashedly corneas knew Kyrie five
boots in honor of sponge robert square
to knit we're gonna be unveiling some
all some other Kyrene also the grumpy
boys we just started calling him the
grumpy boy's name is became the grumpy
boys yeah the debut of house Carissa
somehow Melo survive being launched from
the catapult but I guess he used the
same super power he had from him
surviving we've pushed down the moon
door well you know I for one thing
you've been treated so unfairly by all
those blog boy media folk analytics
people a night of your caliber you sir
should be on a house ridiculous thank
you well you know this was our kind of
commentary here how like every player
was like someone's got a sign mellow
someone should sign mellow but no we
would actually like want to like go to
their DM and say hey it's like
everyone's talking like they're so
offended that nobody would sign mellow
but like none of them actually took the
steps to get them signed until when you
house blazes hood put on how sixes Hey
gifted guys so I was wondering if here's
where very quickly explain some so box
you see Gordon Hayward smashed it it's a
long story
oh wow okay what even happens when you
smash a soul box
thank you so much for having us we're
very upset well we like his voice is
sort of like like Ronnie soup cut really
one guy
so right now we're bronze really rubbing
in the fact that they all actually don't
have rivalries they're all friends and
that's the gyro with the old players so
he's on the medieval version of
Instagram here on his Bravin generation
is soft of your load management your
analytics really happening or is it a
vision last time I heard Benny wasn't
man Derrick Rose had a vision Judah
who's getting along what's I think he
muddy in my special boy junior
[Music]
this background looks so good shout out
to Elliot and Tom and Richard our
background team moved away and then Tom
our comp guy who uh me an incredible job
thing the scene looks great good we're
more than just the cloth
I love this shot
going on here this is loosely based on
the very first scene from Game of
Thrones when they find the little white
girl it sounds weird to say but you
would have called white from the show so
that's the mailman farm alone what's
going on amidst great jazz fans bursitis
is like the second time we've shown a
jazz player no no we have a lot of
Donovan Mitchell so this was hard for us
to do but notice the Posey and it broke
our heart and that leads us into our
four-part series finale which starts
tomorrow at noon
so a couple of final check it out
so Austin Fang says did you add me PI
Monday to lighten the scene a bit I
don't think so I think we just did it
because we thought it was like sort of
funny yeah we really like John's
position between like the dark scenes
and then the exciting fun scenes but I
think that's really the you know that's
really it for for questions I just want
to say to everyone thank you guys so
much for being a part of this and for
dealing with us you know in our annoying
talking over everything
Craig you want to give any special
shoutouts anyone yeah and well first of
all I want to thank Alex Erik Michael
and Steve who have been running all the
technical stuff behind the scenes that
this is possible thank you guys so much
and also our entire programming theme
our entire programming team and
marketing team all the people that have
always supported gamers owns and make it
possible at bleacher report it's a
really good group of people and and also
I just want to say to everyone thank you
guys so much for being Fanning's we
really appreciate this and and we hope
you enjoy the final season and you
enjoyed our little watch party and if
this is annoying of having us talk over
the whole thing you can watch the whole
thing on you
and tomorrow check it out
our season 1 series finale poor part
starts Thursday and then it'll be every
Thursday after that so goodbye Mike
thank you everyone
from James Harden to all of you I wish
you only the best euro steps and may you
draw many fouls in the future as
beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]